fine I'll do it myself
[Music]
[Applause]
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so big news
Thanos is on the set of Infinity Ward
they've started filming scenes I'm sure
they're doubling up for the other movies
that he's going to appear in but Josh
Brolin in full mocap speaking the words
that are going to crush the universe so
it's so excited so let's break it down
so we just love that his mocap suit is
purple it just feels appropriate like
you could make it gray if you wanted to
but they just went like the extra step
beyond that it made it purple like the
enosis skin so because we haven't seen a
whole lot of in the NCU I think that
they've slowly been tuning him just a
little bit the way they write him the
way they write his dialogue if you go
back in fact I'd actually recommend you
go back and re-watch his scenes during
guardians of the galaxy like the kind of
anachronistic way with which he speaks
like he's actually holding court he has
a castle here only it's just a castle of
rubble he sits on top of a pile of
rubble as if this is what the universe
would look like under his rolled part of
the problem with that is that it is very
true to the comics you're like oh yeah
you know it sounds like the Thanos that
I remember reading in infinity quest and
Infinity Gauntlet infinity war but the
problem is is when you put them on
screen with characters that don't also
speak like that like as Guardians speak
in a very Shakespearean way coming out
of Anthony Hopkins mouth anything sounds
amazing but then when you bring like
regular character like you know average
people will not so average people but
normal humans like Tony Stark or say
like Hawkeye Hawkeye is probably like
the most normal person out of all the
Avengers like he lives in the woods
he's so removed from all this grandeur
all this craziness that's going on so we
just like I fire arrows there's an army
of robots outside this is ridiculous
none of this makes any sense he's like
the character during age of Ultron who
just acknowledges how ridiculous it all
is and that's kind of what happens when
you put those characters on screen with
a nose which is going to happen during
infinity war so I think in weaving him
in very slowly throughout all these
movies they've been tuning him just a
little bit like just trying to figure
out what the right mixture of grandeur
and ridiculousness works on-screen with
real characters like they want it to be
true to the comics but they don't want
you to laugh at him you're actually
supposed to be pretty
afraid of him he's supposed to be
terrifying so if he starts doing too
many these and too many vowels and you
just completely takes you out of it and
people won't take it seriously
so one of the first things I think
they'll probably do or they probably
done already because he's probably gonna
show up and Thor Ragnarok a little bit
is that they'll reduce the amount of
actual dialogue that he has he's way
better when he's just smiling at you
like an insane person like oh my god oh
my god what's gonna do next but we've
never seen him get out of that chair and
I know the funny thing like he's
actually gotten out of the chair by the
time he gets that glut but he has to
stand up to put the gauntlet on in that
post-credit scene so he's already stood
up but he's sitting down here so it's
almost like he still has not gotten out
of the chair but you're still thinking
that funny Thor video who is the purple
man does not like to sit up so let me
know in the comments when we actually
see that os-- on-screen how do you think
that they're going to change him from
the comics now visit like I think
they're going to do it as close to the
comics as they can but I feel like the
dialogue is going to get tuned just a
little bit so that it's a little less
ridiculous but if you're wondering where
they're actually at in the filming of
infinity war they're just getting
started they were putting out casting
notices for extras the Russos posted
this picture when it actually got
started when they actually went to
Atlanta like it's on like
they're filming it at the same place
where they film guardians of the galaxy
where they film spider-man homecoming
but like Marvel has just kind of taken
over Atlanta for the last couple of big
films with the exception of Thor
Ragnarok that's the only movie that's
happening right now that isn't being
filmed in Atlanta but the thing about
doing scenes with Thanos like the reason
why they could probably do him earlier
is is because they're doing Thor
Ragnarok right now they need some Santos
in that movie so it makes sense that
they would bunch up Josh Brolin shooting
dates so that they could film scenes for
Thor Ragnarok you know like green screen
type scenes and they would also go
back-to-back with that shoot their
infinity war material with him too so
you don't necessarily need all the other
actors on screen with Josh Brolin as
long as the directors are there and they
can build the environment necessary for
him to do the scene the way it needs to
be done you know like if you don't need
other actors there and then actors that
good thing great sometimes you actually
need like another human being there too
act with it's really helpful for the
actors so the Russos look like they're
just kind of talking him through a scene
here but just to do a quick history of
Thanos the way the Marvel has been using
him in the Marvel Universe you have to
go all the way back to that first
Avengers film there was going to be way
more Thanos than that then was actually
in the final cut of the movie Joss
Whedon was the first person who came
along it was like whoa whoa whoa pump
the brakes on Thanos you got a weave him
it way slower so credit where credit is
due
a lot of Marvel's phase 1 phase 2 phase
3 plans up to infinity war for Thanos
started with Joss Whedon now obviously
later directors like James Gunn the
Russos have decided how to use it you
know so his performance in those movies
will largely be attributed to those
directors but Joss Whedon is like the
granddaddy of the Thanos plans in the
MCU so come to guardians of the galaxy
the first time we actually see him on
screen so what ended up happening is is
they didn't cast Josh Brolin until right
before they film that scene which
happened after they'd already done
pretty much the entire movie like they
did at the very end of production as
they were finishing post-production
because one I think they were kind of
trying to keep it a bit of a secret so
they wanted to wait till like the last
possible minute just in case something
got out into he was in so few scenes
they didn't really need him to be on
screen with the other actors so they
just they brought him in to like a green
screen you know like the way they shoot
Tony Stark's heads-up display stuff like
Robert Downey jr. goes into a green
screen room speaks the lines in and they
just digitally put all that other
heads-up display stuff on top of them so
it looks like he's inside the helmet
it's kind of the same thing with Thanos
like they shoot Josh Brolin in a mocap
suit speaking the lines and then they
add all the CG later like it's all done
in a computer so all that happened for
guardians of the galaxy like at the very
end of production on that movie so you
know very little fan OHS that's still
pretty cool I mean he didn't like get up
and run around he didn't kill anyone
himself he just sat there in the chair
smiled yelled just a little bit and then
there was the small tag at the end of
age of Ultron just kind of throwing
forward to what's going to be happening
in infinity war fine I'll do it myself
also just a very short scene that they
brought Josh Brolin in at the very end
of that movie for
- thor ragnarok now obviously we haven't
seen footage of the movie yet so we
don't know exactly how he's going to
show up but presumably we're gonna see
other characters the characters that we
know like Loki interacting with him in
some small way
part of the mission now leading into
infinity war is better explaining what
Thanos is doing why he wants to do it
what the Infinity Gauntlet is because
there's so many people that are gonna
see these movies that have absolutely no
idea what happened in the comics so part
of what Marvel has been doing on top of
you know what's going to be happening in
the movies is doing these funny Thor
trailers because it's just reminding you
of the Infinity Gauntlet the Infinity
stones as they call him in the movies
and then hoping that you go back and you
watch the old movies again like you
watch guardians of the galaxy and you
listen to the collectors speech about
the relics that predate the creation of
the universe there was also a seat where
Odin kind of does the same thing like I
think it's when Jane Foster first comes
to Asgard and they're walking through a
chamber and he opens the book and
explains the Dark Elves like there's the
book with the text that moves around he
explains the Infinity stones while
that's going on - so just expect more
scenes like that in the next couple
movies where you're cut like subtly
reminded like hey remember there's an
Infinity Gauntlet there's a bunch of
powerful stones and then there's a
purple guy in a chair like Thor's trying
to figure out so really what I'm hoping
for from like the Russos is there
filming Infinity Ward you know these are
teasing stuff out on Instagram like
little pictures just like little winks
at what they're doing is they show
another actor working here with Josh
Brolin in his mocap suit so you're like
oh my god we're finally going to see
Robert Downey jr. try to out wisecrack
Thanos I don't think it's going to work
I don't think he's going to be able to
wisecrack his way out of that situation
or even a scene like this you know with
him hoisting spider-man up above his
arms that'd be so funny to see Josh
Brolin like pick up Tom Hall and just
chuck them across the room but let me
know in the comments what kind of
behind-the-scenes stuff do you want to
see from infinity war now obviously you
want to see everything like way we want
the trailer now give it to us now but
it's going to be a long time before we
actually see real footage the next
footage we see of Thanos will actually
be in someone else's movie so it's going
to be a lot of fun and they're going to
be filming that movie for a long time
infinity war is such a huge movie
they're going to be filming it like you
won't see all the actors
on screen together like you know filming
scenes together that much most of it
will be just a couple of actors together
at a time so either way just be prepared
you're going to be seeing little stuff
like this from behind the scenes for the
rest of the year and into the first part
of next year but what's going to happen
next is I'm probably gonna do like a
narrow behind-the-scenes video because
we've seen the new team arrow in their
comic book costumes mr. terrific has
like full-on face paint like the tea on
his face Bowl on comic book mr. terrific
is gonna be a lot of fun so I'll
probably post a video for that tomorrow
there's a couple other trailers that I
want to do so just be sure to subscribe
to get all that stuff and there is a new
round of the Captain America Civil War
giveaway going on right now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video it's just for a
copy of the blu-ray so I'll announce the
winner the next time I post a Marvel
video well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for all my
spider-man homecoming behind the scenes
and you can click here to learn all
about Thor Ragnarok thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight